there are so few certainties
right now yeah everything is up in the
air but that's kind of where
guys like us thrive yeah that's why i i
don't mind it i don't mind it i
i actually like it i don't mind it um
final question yeah i just want to say
like i knew
we were going to win the pandemic yeah i
knew this well i appreciate it
but i knew this yes at the beginning
yeah i knew this
yeah i would not be surprised if we
didn't have text message conversations
about this we're probably dead it's just
and what does two sociopaths just going
we're going to win the pandemic yeah
like the the news being like there's
another mobile more than a thousand
people
like we're gonna win this and i'm like i
agree that's you my head videos pop yeah
it sounds crazy but at the same time
like
when there's chaos yeah certain people
can thrive in that
right because chaos one what is about
the people that took this period
off [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] what about the people that
left the places and went like people
that just
didn't fight this out well does that say
something about their their character
they're different between leaving
they're different between leaving and
not fighting
okay because like i think la is horrible
the way that this is it's a horrible
place everything's [ __ ] close
it's horrible it's horrible when it's
over it's not to see
i think maybe worse like you can't live
here with everything closed down
even if it's very bad like you and i are
from new york yeah they said they've
been closing things down forever i can
go get a burger and place so i won't
yeah they literally said i'm not gonna
say the place
but like a very nice restaurant in new
york
i had a party of like 12 people right
right we're all good because we're
getting tested for netflix right
i know right literally everybody does
not have corona
right right right for a fact of course
so we're having a little celebration
there i look at
certain people where i go like i was
like
i feel like some people rose to the
occasion in terms of just working yeah
just work
yeah i love working right yeah yeah i
was a drug addict so if i'm not working
i'm in trouble doing drugs
correct so at the end of the day i just
look at certain people and i go and i
get it if you're a young comic i get it
i get like no no yeah yeah yeah you're
right
about the restaurant good point you're
not wrong they said they said number 10
people yeah it has to be under 10 people
i call the guy i'm like
i got 12 people can you do this of
course that's new york everything's
negotiable it's negotiable everything's
negotiable so it's like
did people think oh new york is all shut
down nothing's shut down right i got a
slice of pizza if i wanted to figure it
out
whatever but the same thing it's like yo
if you're a young comic and you're
getting paid by the government to not do
anything
and you're better fighting [ __ ] you're
crazy [ __ ] nuts dude yeah which is
i'm proud of the dudes that i work with
you know
ben always you know my that kid dan that
opens for me was out there in florida
making stuff like when you see people
making stuff
it's it's positive ben works his ass off
all the time like to just make the show
better
this whole studio is him this i have
nothing to do with this studio
literally i mean i walked in i saw him
like it's amazing i have nothing to do
with this
studio yeah i mean ben coordinated this
entire thing
yeah so it's like just find i think a
way to work
yeah and don't wait like there's too
many people right now that are like
waiting they're like waiting
for someone to open the barn door it's
like guys we're good like they get upset
at us i think a lot of times and it's
i think it's because they don't like the
fact that we took our career
in our own hands right and i think it
kills them that they exist on the
charity
of others yes where we exist on
connectivity of people
like my career is because people [ __ ]
with me and that's always been the way
it was
that's it like if i ever was on a show
the executives
never really liked me they would test it
you know what it's called like focus
group or something yeah yeah focus group
they focus group it and then like i do
really well and they're like oh i guess
people like this kid
right right so for me put me in front of
the people give me the people that's all
i care about
i want to say especially with the
[ __ ] netflix thing like i want to
express what i think most people are
actually feeling
and nobody's [ __ ] saying or very few
of us are saying
and it's like that's where i put my
faith in i literally
put my faith in people i have tons of
faith in people yeah
i don't but i they find me funny and
that's okay like
that is yeah yeah yeah yeah and they
finally
no but i get in a way i do because they
finance yeah they fun things like listen
at the end of the day i do think people
can recognize
uh funny yes and i think they can
recognize funny and like being authentic
yeah it's like people i don't know it's
not that [ __ ] hard people act like
being like
like a talent exec is a hard job it's
like we make it
it's not a hard job at all yeah it's
like i could tell you're funny
yeah like when i saw the videos i was
like oh yeah this guy's got it funny
yeah that's it
you know what i mean like ryan long we
were talking funny funny kid like i
could tell he's got it you got it right
so it's like and then i see certain
people
and i go you're trying really hard you
don't have it yet maybe you won't ever
get it but you might get it but you
might get it but you don't have it yet
yeah and that's just what it is what's
the t that's so that's interesting maybe
to end on
what is the differential between
eventually getting it
and never getting it and and is it even
something that we
even know i think it's just an unknown
i think it's like i think some people
have something that is that
almost everybody can attach onto it's
like lizard
there's like a lizard quality to it
where it's just like oh this
is funny like [ __ ] what is his name
chris farley or whatever
yeah like he had a lizard funny yeah i
don't think he said a single
setup punch in his knife but when he did
things it was
funny amazing and you laugh right and
it's lizard
right primal [ __ ] right yeah so some of
us have
eddie murphy people like that too primal
yeah right like
bernie mac primal right
some of us have a primal connectivity
right some people
will have 60 000 fans that really relate
to their specific experience
and having that fan base has never
existed in history except right now
maybe with culture so like you might not
have it
where the world will gravitate to you
that's
there's only a few of us that are going
to have that but you have the
opportunity with the internet to find
the other 60 000 people
who have existed in life just like you
and you're speaking for them right and
that has
never existed before and now it has so
it's just like figure it out
yeah find those [ __ ] find the people
find the [ __ ] people
yeah so to me that's why it gets
annoying if i hear bitching about [ __ ]
yeah there's just
there's enough avenues out there